if you suddenly found out that your best
friend had horrifying superpowers what
would you do your friend from childhood
will try to kill you along with everyone
else in this city and there's nothing
you can do about it I'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to beat the Akira God in
Akira as in Santa clad we think it's
important to have all my titles in order
that's why established titles have sent
me a certificate to allow me to own at
least one square foot of land on a
private estate in Edison Scotland which
technically makes me alone now guys this
weed King is actually a lord now like I
can officially change my name to Lord
Dom on my credit card and plane tickets
and stuff and I said my peasant Squire
Griffin to go collect my Lord
certificate right as we speak don't tell
Dom this but I actually got the Lord's
certificate for myself
established titles is a Project based on
historic Scottish Customs where
landowners were commonly referred to as
Lords and Ladies in English and they've
made it a fun way to preserve the
natural Woodlands of Scotland while
helping out the world and they plan to
train with every order and work with
global Charities one tree planted and
trees for the future to support Global
reforestation efforts and there's Nova
Wing certificate features a unique plot
Number where you'll be able to see the
exact location of your land where I'll
be building my kingdom as soon as Griff
gets back to me with my Lord title an
application is to be my Wii princess are
down below
established titles will plan a tree with
every order and work with global
Charities around the world to help
repopulate the trees so get it for
yourself or as a last minute gift they
even have couple packs that come with
adjoining plots of land
the first 200 people purchasing a title
pack will effectively be next to my plot
of land it's like I'm a lord lady let's
build my little weed Kingdom using your
sweat and tears they're also running a
Black Friday sale plus if you use the
code how to beat you'll get an
additional 10 off go to established
titles.com how to beat to get your gifts
and help support your boys thank you to
established titles for sponsoring this
video now back to the show everyone in
this city has no idea that they're about
to die it's the year 2019 and this city
has just spent the last 31 years
rebuilding its destroyed self after
World War III Canada and his biker gang
friends leave their favorite bar in Neo
Tokyo and go hop on their bikes that's
when he sees his best friend tetsuo
fangirling over his motorbike but Canada
tells him that he can't handle that much
horsepower shoving him off at he gets on
his own bike and the Gang rides off but
Canada here has no idea what horrifying
things his best friend is about to do in
another part of the city an injured man
drags this strange kid through this
gridlock as he shoots these two dogs on
his tail nearby the police hear the
shots and tell him to stop running but
he tells the kid to run while the man
buys him time he points his gun at the
police only to get fatally shot on the
floor he tells the kid to go get help
from a man called real and he dies on
the scene the boy is horrified and yells
causing everything around him to get
destroyed just as he disappears
elsewhere Canada's gang rides throughout
the city just as they meet another rival
biker gang the two groups Chase each
other around causing havoc and
destruction everywhere they go Canada
rides his bike from the other side and
charges down one of the rival gang
members and the two bikers play a game
of chicken the rival gang member chokes
at the last minute and crashes just as
Akira pulls his signature badass move
but this cocky kid's attitude will get
his friends killed soon enough suddenly
the cops are hurt and both biker gangs
make a break for it but as they come
under this bridge one of the Rival
members tries to slow down Akira's crew
by throwing a bomb at them his gang
suddenly pull over but his best friend
tetsuo keeps on rioting and he chases
and knocks down one of the gang members
distracted tetsuo then looks forward
just as he sees this kid walking right
in front of him and the two brutally
crash into each other causing an
explosion Canada and his crew finally
catch up and rush to tetsuo's side he
looks around and sees this kid and is
shocked when he finally reveals his face
suddenly helicopters all around them
show up and this guy Colonel mustache
walks up to them he tells Kane does gang
to drop to the floor and they watch
helplessly as the military kidnaps
tetsuo and that ugly looking kid right
in front of their eyes okay these kids
have just had front row seats to what
will ultimately be their horrifying
downfall because this city has gone
Balls to the walls over the last 31
years since it got brutally destroyed
and since then has rebuilt itself on top
of these artificial Islands so to like
those badass Palm Islands over in Dubai
but this isn't a city you want to live
in as it's scary as hell and plagued by
crime corruption and terrorism and this
is the reason why martial law has been
declared all over neo-tokyo however
while martial law could explain the
sudden Landing of these helicopters and
overall badassery of this Japanese
military force taking over [ __ ] what
doesn't make sense is why this ugly
Benjamin Button wannabe kid that we just
saw right now it makes me wonder and
terrified as hell as to the reason
behind why the military is here and
wants this kid so freaking bad now we
don't have much information to work with
it's unlikely that the military would
waste their resources arresting a bunch
of snotty nose kids when the police
force could do the job just as well
however the first thing we saw after the
crash and right before the military
showed up was this wrinkly nasty looking
kid and he's the only one here who seems
out of place and sus as hell and based
on his facial features seems like he has
a case of something known as
Hutchinson's Guilford syndrome which is
a genetic condition characterized by the
dramatic appearance of Aging beginning
in childhood the fact is this kid is
looking like this and obviously means
something is biologically out of order
within him whether that's because he's
infected with some sort of obscure gene
mutation or has some problems with his
endocrine system either way this kid is
a biological weirdo and someone that the
military clearly has a deep interest in
otherwise they wouldn't have sent a
full-on military task force just to
arrest a bunch of teenagers they're not
after them and them taking our best good
for nothing friend tetsuo likely means
that he is now of high interest towards
the military after his encounter with
this kit otherwise why would they take
him they would have just left him
otherwise because tetsuo's crash
happening right near this kid seems to
correlate with the both of them being
taken at the same time and this kid
looking like a genetic Abomination
likely means that tetsuo will be
subjected to some kinds of tests to do
with this kid and it likely won't be at
your regular hospital since again these
guys are from the military and I've
watched enough movies to know that the
military would do just about anything to
keep their country safe even if it means
conducting horrifying experiments on our
asses which they could simply justify I
doing as a matter of National Security
this makes taking our tetsuo here scary
as hell and if I was Canada I'd have two
options one call it a day and ditch my
friend move on with my life and forget
about it but if he really is my dear
friend I would look into this kid and
any correlation that I could find
between him and the country's military
or like I said it could simply cut my
losses and get a new best friend like
this guy since he looks pretty you know
half decent and at least he hasn't tried
to steal my bike yet later at the police
precinct Canada makes up some pathetic
excuse to this cop about what his
friends were doing up on that bridge and
somehow the cop buys his excuse and
tells them to wait outside of the office
there Canada sees a girl sitting across
from him and thinks she's a certified
Baddie but Canada has no idea what
terrifying things this girl will make
him do soon suddenly this cop comes out
and tells Canada that him and his group
of friends are free to go but anyways
Cheeky Canada here also sneaks out this
stranger girl with him and they leave
the police precinct outside Canada tries
his best to flirt with with this girl
but she says that she doesn't have time
and is on an important and terrifying
Mission the mysterious girl then leaves
before poor horned dog Canada finds out
her name elsewhere inside a top secret
lab Colonel mustache meets with this
Einstein wannabe doctor and he reveals
something terrifying he tells the
colonel that they're getting a very
special psychic reading from the old kid
that Canada saw earlier this old kid is
known as Takashi the doctor says that he
thinks that takashi's accelerated
psychic powers came thanks to the bike
accident he had earlier with Canada's
friend tetsuo the colonel is concerned
as hell and asks the doctor if Takashi
could end up having powers like their
former prisoner known as Akira but the
doctor reassures him that in case he
does they should be able to control it
this time and that was their biggest
mistake inside the machine a barely
conscious tetsuo here's the name Akira
and he plans to escape from this
hellhole later tetsuo's love interest in
Bay is doing laundry when he shows up
having escaped from previously mentioned
hell hole he tells her that he wants
them to run away together she agrees and
the two end up stealing Canada's sick
bike and they drive off not paying
attention they drive through a rival
biker gang territory not being able to
handle the horsepower tetsuo ends up
stalling the bike just as this biker
gang catches up with them they injured
tetsuo's Bay and are about to burn
Canada's bike when Canada and his gang
show up to save the day again they chase
off the gang members when Canada then
lectures tetsuo about how he's always
saving his sorry ass and this angers
tetsuo he walks off but suddenly gets
hit with a massive headache right as
this creepy van shows up with all of
these scientists along with the same man
they saw up on the bridge last night
Colonel mustache and his team kidnaps
tetsuo again okay fool me once shame on
you fool me twice and I'll beat the
wimness right out of you because this
time we know for a fact that the
government wants our friend badly and
them showing up right as tetsuo
collapsed means that the government was
watching us for at least him and let's
not forget our best but is kind of a
useless numbskull of a [ __ ] that is
always in need of our help he's
basically the anime version of Frodo
from Lord of the Rings now us being us I
would have left him to the Wolves since
this piece of [ __ ] stole our sweet ass
iconic ride and that means that tetsuo
here deserves to die right on the spot
but for funsies if we were to imagine us
helping him then upon seeing him Canada
should for tetsuo's sake slammed a bat
or something hard right in front of his
Japanese face to knock him the hell out
because right before Colonel mustache
showed up it is noted that tetsuo
complained of a major migrant that
practically knocked him out and rendered
him useless knowing that the government
had abducted him there's no way that we
could have known just what the hell they
did to him so by helping him out by
bringing him to a pharmacy would have
been foolish since a we wouldn't have
known why he was feeling ill and based
on how lifeless he got it's unlikely
that he would have been able to last us
on the bike with us by knocking him out
unconscious since we don't know what
ungodly things those people did to him
however his bitching attitude would have
at the very least been silenced at least
temporarily then by using using the tie
that Canada's friend here was wearing we
could have positioned unconscious tetsuo
to sit behind us on our bike while his
hands could have been tied around our
waist this would have allowed us to ride
off with our pathetic best friend and
kept his mouth shut and also it's noted
that Neo Tokyo is home to the most
degenerate of people on the planet and
is filled with countless gangs and bad
people with scary intentions and Canada
being a biker gang member means that his
knowledge of the Shady parts of the city
would have been plentiful enemies that
we could have used his knowledge to hide
within certain gang-filled territories
with our friend while we try to figure
out what the hell is going on and as
long as Canada didn't Spill the Beans
about what he was up to I'm fairly
certain that hiding within the
gang-infested territories means that the
military would have had a hard time
finding a sense well no one likes it
when the law comes in sniffing around in
their neighborhoods because at the end
of the day it's bros before a host at
least until something like a baddie
comes along and then in that case it's
every man for himself later at night
Canada sits and wonders what the hell
the government could want with his best
friend but suddenly an explosion goes
off nearby running away from the
explosion he sees the same Baddie from
earlier called K along with a few other
people suspicious and now in anime love
he chases after the girl who gets
separated from her crew and hides under
this building Canada catching up to her
looks from above as he sees the police
spot her and chase her down the police
Corner her and are about to kill her
when Canada jumps down and saves her
this other cop prepares to kill Canada
when the girl shoots the cop in the face
saving Canada and forcing the two to run
away before police reinforcements arrive
elsewhere Colonel mustache arrives at a
top secret facility as he and Einstein
wannabe head deeper underground into
freezing temperatures the colonel tells
his men to open this giant Frozen door
and he heads inside to see this giant
construct with a sign on top reading
Akira back on the Run Canada tries to
convince his new bay K to turn herself
in and that he'll write her letters
until she gets out but suddenly they run
into this man and case accomplice who
they find out is called Rio and Kay's
crew lock Canada into this room they
discuss a new mission that they've been
given sneak into a laboratory hospital
to gather data on a new test subject
that the government is experimenting on
suddenly they find Canada listening in
and prepared to kill him as they think
he's a spy but he reveals that the
person they're talking about is his best
friend tetsuo and begs them to let him
come they agree and prepare for the most
dangerous Mission yet Canada's new group
then suits up and goes undercover as
electricians and they sneak into the
hospital lab where tetsuo is being held
little do they know that some of them
won't make it out alive nearby tetsuo
struggles to sleep when all of a sudden
he begins to hallucinate this giant toy
creature and all of these creatures
suddenly attack him and make this his
baddest trip yet okay this is horrifying
tetsuo here has been kidnapped illegally
and now at the very least on the surface
tripping balls but whatever world we are
currently in this is likely or the least
partially related to the fact that we've
been placed under lockdown in this
mysterious Hospital Place meaning it's
highly probable that we're under the
influence of at least several types of
drugs one of which was injected into us
earlier now on the surface the
Department of Defense usually agrees to
comply with all civilian FDA regulations
concerning the development and use of
new drugs requiring written consent from
a person in order to receive such drugs
so under usual circumstances tetsuo here
should have been safe from being
injected with any weird [ __ ] since the
government would have needed his consent
before doing anything anyways however
this is Neo Tokyo natal Joe Schmo Tokyo
and a perfect example of tetsuo
situation here actually comes up in 1991
during the Gulf War and it shows exactly
how much the military actually follows
the rules and how the military acted at
that time raised a number of questions
regarding the use of investigative drugs
because in order to protect the soldiers
at that time from being exposed to
dangerous chemicals during the Gulf War
the military requested that the FDA
waive any consent requirements in order
to see the mission through successfully
and in as little time as possible and as
a result thousands of soldiers were
injected with drugs designed to protect
them but ones that they never consented
to this pretty much sums up the exact
situation that tetsuo here is in since
it's clear that the government has
wanted us ever since we crashed into
that kit and if the government has
interest in US you can bet your sweet
chubby cheekers that they'll run through
whatever red tape that they have to in
order to get what they want and inject
us with whatever they want because in
this world it is martial law this makes
tetsuo hear unprepared as health on how
to deal with these trippy monsters and
knowing tetsuo's character from the
get-go it seems as though he's a man
with an ego problem since it's clear
that he has some unresolved issues with
his best friend Canada and it's likely
that he lacks any inherent self-worth
since he's been trying to prove to
Canada this whole time who are a big boy
he is his state of mind being so
negative could have likely started this
bad trip to begin with however there's
one thing to note that makes me think we
could get out of this it's clear that
from the beginning these toy monsters
have been toy with tetsuo from climbing
the bed to needlessly chasing him around
the room these creatures have been
acting slow as hell and it seems like
that what they really want to do is to
put on a show not harm him but just
scare him into submitting if tetso here
simply crawls up into a ball and ignores
everything around him this makes me
think that it's possible that all of
this will stop since by choosing to not
engage with these people these things
he'll stop annoyingly participating in
their sick game if we're hallucinating
then closing our eyes and ignoring
everything will mean that we can stop
all of this or we can go the fun way if
I'm tetsuo it's my mind and my rules
which means in here I am God which means
I get to open my Pandora's Box and
unleash all sorts of mental hell that I
have cooked up in my devious Ray I would
terrify them to the point that they just
leave me alone tetsuo freaks the hell
out as he tries to dodge these adorable
little beasts but suddenly he cuts his
foot on some glass and bleeds and this
causes the hallucinations to stop he
then finds out the people responsible
for his bad trip these two old wrinkly
looking children who then get scared and
disappeared and that was their biggest
stake tattoo then becomes enraged and
suddenly discovers his powers he breaks
out of the locked room and brutally
kills this doctor and the guards with
ease more guards show up and try to stop
him but this only angers tetsuo who
evolves into a murdering killing machine
elsewhere Canada's crew tries to find
tetsuo by sneaking through the sewer
system when they are suddenly discovered
by a guard who kills one of their
members the group begins exchanging fire
killing a few of the guards as [ __ ] hits
the fan Canada then steals one of the
guard's bikes and he saves K and flies
the hell out of there but suddenly K
starts acting weird and starts getting
instructions on where to go they then
hear on the bike radio of the
whereabouts of tetsuo and they learn
that he's turned into this superhuman
killer and is carrying on his killing
Rampage murdering everyone in this
facility tetsuo finally reaches this
strange childlike room and there he
encounters the same old wrinkly looking
children from earlier but now his powers
are too strong and he defeats them with
ease cornering them and we find out the
names of these strange superhero-like
beings the one in the glass is Kyoko the
one on the the left is Takashi the same
kid who crashed into tetsuo in the
beginning and the one on the right is
some extra random character that I don't
care to mention the name of the three
try to stop tetsuo and begin having a
horrific psychic battle but suddenly
they are interrupted by Colonel mustache
and Einstein wannabe who tells tetsuo
that his powers haven't matured yet and
then he needs to continue taking his
medicine or he'll soon die or horrible
death Kyoko then telepathically tells
tetsuo about someone more powerful than
him maimed Akira this shocks and angers
tetsuo as he says that Akira is the one
to blame for invading his mind and
causing him all of this pain he demands
to know where Akira is and attacks the
children nearly destroying the whole
building suddenly Canada and K fly in
and crash right in front of him Canada
then tells his best friend tetsuo that
they need to leave but is horrified when
he sees tetsuo kill a bunch of arriving
soldiers right in front of him this
isn't the tetsuo he once knew tetsuo
laughs and says that he doesn't need
kanida to save him anymore and that he
is the new top G around here however
this anchors Canada which in turn pisses
off tetsuo even more and he prepares to
hurt him badly okay okay Canada here has
just found out that his bestie is a
psycho super powered freak and it makes
sense that due to their big brother
little brother relationship that tetsuo
suddenly not needing Canada anymore
would make anyone feel a certain type of
way however Canada here is acting way
too emotional and needs to calm the
frick nuts down it's obvious that both
of these boys are acting their situation
out perfectly in line with their
character I mean they are hormone-filled
law disturbing teenagers who both think
that they're too cool for school but
this is why Canada needs to approach the
situation with some foresight tetsuo
here is already on a power trip and is
acting out of pure Spite and anger and
Canada bringing in even more emotions to
this situation will only add fuel to the
already psychedelic fire now while
Canada might not have known that tetsuo
is about to take a step up from just a
villain to a straight-up certified super
villain we know that he already heard on
the radio that tetsuo was on her
murderous killing Rampage therefore it
makes sense that despite not knowing
about his Newfound Powers trying to
resolve the situation with his best
friend would have been the way better
move to help both of them out since
remember we are in a military facility
run by people who clearly have no
boundaries and have no problem killing
us if we get in their way which I
totally respect this is why instead of
trying to one-up tetsuo Canada should
have resorted to the five-step
behavioral change stairway model that
was developed by the FBI's hostage
negotiation unit this process was
designed to get someone else to see a
new point of view and change their
course of action within a short time
span which would have resulted in tetsuo
coming to an agreement with Canada and
acting upon a newly suggested plan of
action that Canada could have suggested
whether that was tetsuo acting too crazy
and that he needed to calm down or that
since both of these boys were in trouble
tetsu could have allowed Canada to get
him out of there and that they will talk
more about their rocky relationship
later there were many options that
Canada could have went with if he just
stuck to this five-step process which he
didn't do because both of these kids
were acting like self-entite titled
know-it-all little punks AKA teenagers
in general which at the moment was the
wrong move and this will cost someone
here their life tetsuo flips his [ __ ]
and blows up the floor around him
sending Canada flying back just then
Kyoko here demands that tetsuo stop
hurting people or else but this Killer
looks at her dead in the eyes and uses
his mind-reading powers to find out that
Akira is located in a stadium across
town horrified Kyoko tries to stop him
and he blasts out of the building with a
newly discovered superpower this guy can
now fly starting across the city he
begins to prepare his plan to kill
everyone back at the lab Colonel
mustache finds out that tetsuo is
heading to the underground facility
where Akira is stored and he readies his
armies to go stop him but they don't
realize that it's already too late later
Canada's group is thrown into prison and
Canada and K end up sharing a cell and
they can do nothing but wait out this
[ __ ] show Canada then asks her who or
what this mysterious Akira is and why is
every everyone after him she tells him
that from what she's heard Akira is
Absolute Energy she explains that the
energy for Consciousness and and
knowledge the thing that all living
things share comes from somewhere and
that according to the evolutionary
theory humans evolved from apes who
evolved from fish and so on and so on
but she asks Canada what if a fish was
gifted the higher knowledge and power of
a human would it be able to handle so
much power in its simple mind or what
it's self-destruct this is what the
Government tried to experiment on with
Akira 30 years ago and what is happening
to tetsuo right now this is what caused
the fall of Tokyo all those years ago
continent listens in shock and horror
about his best friend but doesn't
realize that his beloved K is being mind
controlled by three psychic children
suddenly their cell door opens up and
the two quickly Escape later back near
Canada's biker bar one of his biker
buddy hides from the cops nearby just as
he sees Canada and k run past him
through an Al he follows and meets up
with him near this River and he tells
them the worst possible news tetsuo last
night destroyed their beloved biker bar
and brutally murdered one of his biker
friends he also informs him that the
government has now officially declared
martial law in the city and that [ __ ]
with tetsuo is about to hit the fan
suddenly however Canada sees Takashi
taking a hypnotized K away and they
freaking Jesus walk out of there and
vanish Canada gets angry and then hears
kyoko's voice as she tells him that
she's taken K away in hopes that she'll
be able to help them stop tetsuo she
mentions that deep down everyone has the
power of Akira but because tetsuo chose
to use his powers for evil he must be
killed elsewhere in the city the streets
are closed off as this tank crew spots a
helicopter crash right in front of them
and they see tetsuo Rise Above the
Flames like the Devil Himself he's gone
full-on super villain and this tank
fires a big fatty right at him and that
was a big mistake tetsuo slows the tank
shell to a near stop and then destroys
it with ease this only makes him more
angry the flippity flim flame is this
tetsuo here has officially become a
full-on super villain and it makes me
wonder why is it always the best [ __ ]
crazy people that get all the coolest
[ __ ] it's not fair I'm crazy why don't I
get any cool stuff tetsuo here just
stopped a tank shell mid-flight that is
so freaking cool and has now become
Humanity's biggest threat what we found
out so far that we had to cut cause uh
anime Exposition is that tetsuo here is
part of the project a military
experiment designed to bring about
psychic abilities in humans and Kane the
most long-winded way possible told us
that everyone is capable of having
psychic powers and that this dormant
power is hidden within everyone and so
far the military has had at least 41
test subjects known to display such
Powers now out of all these test
subjects only one has managed to destroy
Tokyo entirely and that person was Akira
he lost control of his own powers and
destroyed everything now it's not clear
on the mental stability of all the other
super powered candidates most notably
the short old wrinkly looking kids
however we know for a fact that tetsuo
here is off his rocker and was never
mentally chill to begin with and that at
this point he's now officially developed
psychic powers from telekinesis
telepathy and flight this makes him a
serious threat and one that I can't for
the life of me wonder why the military
is simply using direct means of attack
against someone who's proven to be
stronger and more capable than anything
the Japanese government is capable of
using however the one thing that we do
have on our side here is what the
colonel said earlier all the psychic
test subjects were injected with drugs
that puts limits on their powers and
prevented them from losing control and
getting too powerful and to die this
means that tetsua whether he realizes it
or not is on a Time clock this means
that if I was in their shoes I would
work on trying to stall tetsuo by
sending air and ground forces or at the
very least using some sort of
surface-to-air type of missile and
knowing that tetsuo is an international
threat means that Japan's government
would have had an easier time asking for
support from other countries to come and
help blow their country to all hell
we're not trying to kill him it's
obvious we can't we're simply trying to
buy time until the drugs in his system
meant to help him finally wear off
allowing him to die without our help and
yes I know that attacking him with
explosive ordinances over long range
would no doubt kill many more Japanese
citizens but well you know sometimes you
have to be a certified Thug in order to
get what you want stay in school kids
the tanker dudes are horrified and they
try to reload and fire again but tetsuo
brutally crushes them in a ball of fire
and metal tetsuo carries on towards the
stadium where Akira is being kept
killing anyone who gets in his way
leading an army of crazed protesters
tetsuo finally reaches the bridge into
the stadium and the Army tries to kill
him with freaking laser beams but he
blocks it and kills everyone on the
bridge all the while as he carries on
walking tetsuo finally reaching the
stadium takes the lift down into the
basement on the way down he suddenly
collapses on the floor in pain having
the worst headache of his life he tries
to forget about it and keep moving but
this is a horrifying sign of the things
to come he enters the Frozen chamber
reaching the Akira Vault just then he
sees K appear under the mind control of
the psychic children she tells him that
soon he won't be able to control his
powers and will die a horrible death but
tetsuo doesn't listen and the two go at
it outside Canada finally reaches all
suited up with his bike and is ready to
stop tetsuo but just then in the
distance he sees the entire chamber of
Akira rise from the floor and sees
tetsuo standing on top of it like a god
the world looks on in sheer Terror as
tetsuo prepares to get to Akira however
K shows up and tries to fight him
destroying everything near them they
fight until K gets knocked back tetsuo
then walks up to the Vault where Akira
is being stored and he blasts it apart
but here he discovers something
horrifying inside the Vault he sees
canisters of brain tissue and organs
Colonel mustache then tells tetsuo
through loudspeaker that after Akira's
Awakening and the destruction of Tokyo
31 years ago Akira's body underwent
every scientific test possible and that
his corpse was systematically broken up
and that it was all Frozen for future
generations to study Akira is already
dead shocked tetsuo then arranges all
the canisters around him just as Canada
shows up anime style to save the day
this time carrying a laser weapon tetsuo
laughs and says that now he has powers
he's the top G and Canada readies his
weapon okay Canada has finally come face
to face with tetsuo again except this
time he's only gotten more powerful and
can kill him with a snap of his freaking
fingers Canada's decision to fight tetsu
ahead on with a laser gun proves that at
the end of the day he's just a hormonal
teenager that thinks he's a bigger stud
than he is he's an idiot there is simply
no need to confront tetsuo up front when
it was clear that he could tell tetsuo
had been having greater and greater
headaches since he got kidnapped in the
first place something was obviously
getting worse with him confronting
tetsuo was only necessary to appease
Canada's ego and letting tetsuo know
who's still in charge because at the end
of the day tetsuo didn't do anything
terrible to Kane does so far other than
hurt his ego and unsuccessfully steal
his bike earlier even if he played it
smart at this point kanigai should have
made himself even more of an underdog
than he already is and should have
waited in the shadows waiting for his
turn to strike if Canada really wanted
to show tetsuo whose boss so bad then he
should have waited in the distance and
out of sight until the military damaged
tetsuo enough to where Canada could have
come in to attack him it's obvious from
what we've seen that the military will
do whatever it takes to kill him and is
even willing to do even bigger and more
disastrous methods of attacks in order
for them to take him out since after all
tetsuo is the biggest threat to humanity
in 31 years by waiting in the shadows
Canada could have simply tried to take
this kid's head off with Amit Cleaver
specially designed to cut through bone
since even if we don't know what would
have happened trying to cut off the head
would have been a safe bet for pretty
much anybody super powered or not since
the brain up there is the most important
organ system in the human body and I've
seen enough zombie and superhero movies
to know that taking the head off of this
super villain either through cutting it
off or just lasting a hole through it
was probably the best move for Canada if
he just approached this situation more
like a good for nothing sleaze bag hyena
Kanita fires his gray matter Blaster
into tetsuo and he falls over but then
he takes a shot at Canada who takes
cover Canada reveals his head and fires
a final shot at tetsuo but this time
nothing happens revealing that tetsuo is
only getting more powerful frustrated
Canada throws his weapon and tells
tetsuo to fight with his hands like a
mat tetsuo then laughs in his face but
suddenly the air around him lights up
and a huge laser beam shoots down and
causes a terrifying explosion tetsuo
then wakes up from the rubble and
realizes that his arm has been vaporized
off by this government satellite in
space Canada shows up to fight him but
before then tetsuo blasts off into space
and he Rains Down lasers and destruction
onto the city of neo-tokyo it's a [ __ ]
show Canada's friends then suddenly roll
up and try and save him but are stopped
when the satellite laser nearly gets
them killed as we see tetsuo finally
destroyed the space station the
devastated world then takes a breather
for the night as everyone including an
injured tetsuo try and recover and get
themselves ready for what will be a
horrifying day in just a few hours
elsewhere kernel mustache tells Einstein
wannabe that they've set up cameras near
tetsuo and are watching him as they
speak but Einstein wannabe then tells
the colonel that tetsuo's psychic powers
according to his charts are virtually
the same as akirus this means that if
they don't stop him soon millions of
people in Neo Tokyo will die just like
the disaster that happened 31 years ago
later in the night tetsuo's Bay then
shows up and finds tetsuo hiding in the
corner whimpering in pain his headache
has gotten worse and she helps him to
his chair but suddenly he has another
massive headache suddenly causing his
new scrap metal arm to get absorbed into
the chair just then Colonel mustache
shows up and tells him that without his
medicine holding back some of his powers
he will die he then tells him to come
back to the lab but tetsuo blows him
back now desperate ended horrifying pain
tetsuo tells his Bae to go get his
medicine for him but she just stares in
horror in shock suddenly Colonel
mustache shoots him back and we see that
tetsuo's metal arm has suddenly grown
flesh around it he tries to kill Colonel
mustache but is stopped when kanada
shows up with his laser gun Tesla tries
to kill Canada and the two battle it out
Canada then crashes his bike but is
saved by Takashi and the two other
psychic hits who show up from the sky
and head towards the remains of Akira
Canada then fires a final shot at tetsuo
and he falls to the floor but suddenly
due to his growing Powers his arm along
with his entire body begins transforming
and he quickly turns into this
horrifying blob Monster uh okay this is
some crazy ass [ __ ] because now tetsuo
has become the one thing that your
mother warned you about if you ate too
much candy and now tetsuo is going to
pay the price for it he seemingly grown
even more powerful with his psychic
abilities but it's come at the cost of
him losing control it seems as though K
or the old psychic baby that was
controlling her was right about human
beings being unable to handle so much
power both physically and mentally and
since the beginning tetsuo displayed his
actions like that of a child acting like
his prefronto cortex was still
developing and he wasn't even able to
think about how his actions would affect
him in the future so it doesn't help
that he was a teenager when he underwent
all of this it makes me wonder though
would it be possible to train these
psychic abilities into someone who was
already a full-on adult and who'd better
be able to handle the physical and
emotional stress that having such Powers
would come with I would totally sign up
for this but anyways the fact is that
tetsuo here is a walking psychic bomb
and Colonel mustache effectively chose
to die by being stupid and showing up
with a simple firearm to try and stop a
God in order to have a better shot at
stopping tetsuo or at least slowing down
the process Colonel mustache could have
also used tetsuo's Bay the military was
keeping surveillance on him and those
around him and if this was the case then
they would have likely known about
tetsuo's Bay from before and should have
made some effort to have roped her in
and have her help them in stopping
tetsuo this could have been done by
using her to convince tetsuo to come
back to the lab or she could have stuck
tetsuo with the drug herself or if that
was too risky they could have simply
used her as a good old-fashioned
Japanese hostage for somebody being in
charge and someone being a colonel I
must stash him a question as to what the
hell he was thinking with his half-assed
baked plant that now is going to cost
the lives of millions tetsuo's
horrifying body continues to grow at a
freakish rate and he can't stop it
suddenly he pulls his Bae into his flesh
and because of the unstable ground
Canada Falls in too Canada begs for
tetsuo's help and tetsuo says that he
now can't control his transformation and
both of them are forced to watch
tetsuo's Bay get brutally crushed alive
finally Canada manages to pull his gun
free and is able to meet blast his way
out of tetsuo his flesh tentacles then
reach the psychic children while they
ignore him and meditate suddenly Akira's
remains explode and Akira's full body
emerges a blinding light then swallows
up the area and begins to destroy
everything in its path Colonel mustache
is then saved by Kyoko halfway into the
horrifying ball of energy tetsuo begins
dying and calls out to Canada for help
Canada being the bro that he is tries to
save him and goes into the light after
him Takashi and the other psychics then
go in as well to try and save Canada as
a team inside the ball of light kanada
then hears the psychic children's voices
who mentioned that they called Akira to
save the world and take tetsuo away
suddenly the white explosion that
implodes and what happened 31 years ago
happens again destroying all of
neo-tokyo and killing Millions however
Canada and his friends are saved by the
old psychic children with the [ __ ] show
now over Canada this one dude and his
new Bae all Count Their Blessings and
ride off into the destroyed City proving
that as long as you have a baddie in
your arms friends are expendable that
was a crazy one what did you think about
it let us know what you like about it
and what you didn't like about it don't
forget to like subscribe and as always
don't forget to check out our social
media and our how to be playlist